il
pour bienvenue sur diagonale tv spéciale
match topalov contre kamski deux demi
finales du championnat du monde alors
topalov mène ce match par deux victoires
à une
on va voir la partie numéro 7
aujourd'hui et on reçoit pour commenter
cette partie le nouvel invité pour
diagonale t qui est déjà passé sur les
munitions c'est aurélie dacalor
breweries
on va rappeler bref vraiment on l'a dit
dans la première émission oui
donc tu es une joueuse d'échecs de
talent parce que tu as été plusieurs
fois champion de france chez les jeunes
et ça c'est pas donné à n'importe qui il
y en a comme par catégorie et par an
c'est peut être ça va quoi de petits
poussins à juniors 1 voila voila mon
petit poussin poussins pupilles
benjamins cadets juniors minimes cadets
juniors il ya cette catégorie donc à
sept champions de france mixte et sept
champions de france filles parents avec
le 14 encore les énarques qui sont ils
sont bien plus nombreux donc là c'est
plus difficile des champions offre en
échec énarque voilà alors donc tu as été
plusieurs fois championne chez les
poussins chez les mx donc tu as battu
les garçons en fait et tu as été deux
fois vous trois fois chez les filles
enfin là et tu joues si on top 12
le championnat france féminin par
équipes et le top16 aussi quel top du
top
aussi des matchs par équipe en france tu
as joué aussi au championnat de france
nationale le ton est ferme et très dur
très dur
les joueuses comme sophie millet
comme le mira skripchenko comme sa bague
du monde quoi alors tes copines aussi
avec peut-être d'autres joueuses qu'on a
reçues sur des notes et des communes at
il conjugue aussi peut-être aussi très
bonne joueuse aussi un oui très forte
la battue alors elle aussi je crois
qu'elle a battue stefano à labatut
antoine et à stéphane voilà champion du
monde carrément alors on va raconter
avec toi ce match topalov kamski alors
tu connais ses joueurs un peu hein alors
est ce que tu aimes le ch'ti est ce que
tu connais leur style un peu où leur
histoire ou comme ce qui par exemple
mais bon tu sais pas tu sais que comme
ce qui était parti qu'il est revenue au
mystère est d'ailleurs un truc qui te
concerne on peut peut-être parce qu'il a
étudié le droit je crois je voulais
faire des études de médecins ou de droit
il a fait droit en fait il a fait le
voyage mais voilà pas ce que tu fais du
droit comme ce qui est donc été partie
parce que bon il n'arrivait pas en fait
bon les premiers son père aussi je crois
d'ailleurs son père qui était hyper
présent pour lui mais enfin bon il
arrive au top du top il a perdu un match
contre karpov il ya dix bons face on ne
regarde jamais à devenir champion du
monde parce que karpov et kasparov ceci
cela c'est un peu il est parti quelques
années il est revenu égale la coupe du
monde il se retrouve en demi-finale sa
peur du monstre ordinaire qu'on appelle
un retour gagnant ça et là elle face à
topalov donc 7e du match alors la can ce
qu'ils menaient 2 1 lors le match a lieu
en bulgarie chez topalov match très
important puisque le vainqueur jouera le
champion du monde
vij manhattan allende
champion incontesté lorsque le premier
champion du monde est contesté depuis
1993 et la scission de kasparov avec la
fille d cramique avait battu kasparov
m'étais pas reconnue par la fidh bon
c'était quand même le vainqueur de
kasparov donc le 14e champion du monde
classique et l'a donc anand est devenu
le 15e champion du monde topalov qui
numéro un mondial rêve sans doute de
gagner sept couronnes là parce que il a
perdu son match face à cannes ce qui est
ce qu'il va y arriver mais on sait pas
en tout cas là ils doivent battre kamski
c'est la septième du match et s'ils
gagnent ce match vous racontera dans nos
matches sans doute explosif entre le
génie indien et peut-être donc topaloff
ou alors peut-être comme ce qui on va
voir cette septième partie topalov face
à cam ski 7e du match 2 1 pour à
topaloff
on y va dans ce grand match de
championnat du monde demi finale donc
que quatre pour topalov donc c'est parti
pour une ouverture ouvert donc sa
deuxième moitié du match pas mal pour 4
1 topalov a joué pas mal 4e 6 enfin une
française alors une partie types de
parties qu'on a déjà vu dans la
quatrième dans la cinquième du match
dans la quatrième et la cinquième du
match avec philippe d'horme bouche ici
sur des modèles tv puisque on rejoue on
retrouve là vraiment harrachis si calais
des deux sur le calvaire des deux pour
protéger le pur quatre et non pas en c3
c3 il peut se faire clouer par le foie
de verser évidemment ici si et noir
jouent au foot et 4 on joue simplement
c2 c3 et c'est un coup d'épée dans l'eau
c'est même une perte de temps on peut
dire c'est qu'elle est deux on protège
avec ce coup crampes en mai
mais vicieux attention à ce genre de
coups donc ces cinq et on avait vu dans
la partie précédente les blancs avaient
répondu lors c'est là qu'on voit la
préparation pause ouverture les blancs
avaient répondu par le coût tout à fait
jouable cavaliers gf3 lecavalier f3 bien
protégés qui ont des quatre les deux
cavaliers protège les deux pions et là
c'est un autre une autre variante que
nous propose en fait topalov sans doute
pour surprendre aussi l'adversaire ça
c'est important
lui aussi sait des choses des coûts pour
surprendre l'adversaire
les ouvertures et c'est vrai est ce que
tu sais ce à quoi s'attend l'adversaire
pour le surprendre c'est ça pour se
rendre bien sûr que non mais pour se
reprendre
il faut aussi jouer parfois des cours
qui sortent vraiment vraiment des
sentiers battus bako et ça surprend
toujours notamment contre des fours
joueurs qui eux sont habitués à la
théorie et s'attendent à ce que leurs
jolies d'accord donc toi même tu en fait
tu t'attends à jouer des couples n'a pas
prévu avant même la partie d'accord
alors ça c'est important noté en fait
une joueuse créative en fait c'est de
créer du jeu alors qu' on prend des 5
alors les blancs les noirs videmment si
les noirs prennent du plomb heureux ils
vont se retrouver avec ce qu'on appelle
un pion isolé parce que les blancs
manteaux à reprendre sans doute en c5 et
l'opinion des 5 sera isolé ce qui est un
souci donc c'est d'en reprendre plus tôt
de la dame pour éviter cette cette
possibilité-là câble et jf 3 pour les
blancs hélas les blancs c'est à dire que
sacrifice implicitement le pion des
quatre puisque les noirs peuvent le
prendre il s'en prive pas et sociaux est
perdu mais en échange de quoi les blancs
accélère le développement et on sait
qu'aux échecs on vous donne droit au
développement
il faut faire attention à pas donner
trop de coûts de développement pour un
pion fous ces quatre dates des 6 petit
regarder les blancs jouer un deux trois
quatre coups de développement les
colonnes ouverte ici ou semi ouverte en
tout cas sur le
sur le camp ennemi et les noirs ont
sorti que la dame donc malgré le tueur -
j'ai l'air en bon c'est pas se soucier
vraiment faudra se dire que le
développement comptent autant que les
pions vous allez voir pourquoi t'es
relief six toiles et blanc continuent à
se développer ici un vis-à-vis
évidemment tour roy qui est toujours
très intéressant fawcett les blancs les
noirs couvre tout de suite près par le
petit rock et là regardez c'est leur bac
l et b3 regard des 1 2 3 voilà on voit
tout de suite que ce pion et perdu les
noirs évidemment ne peuvent pas défendre
par le 5 puisque le cabinet corps et
d'âme et s'il protège y aura toujours
que deux défenseurs dont de toute façon
les blancs avaient fait donc c'est donc
un pseudo sacrifice théorique on va dire
que c'était extrêmement connue alors qu
a blessé six donc les blancs saïsset
leur prennent en d4 calais prend des
quatre pour les noirs qui échangent un
très vite on est quatre être petit rock
voilà donc là le développement est
terminé on voit que les blancs petite
avance de développement intéressantes
il ya quand même voilà je vous y
concentrer une action ici sur le centre
alors à noter que c'est une position
asymétrique toujours important
trois pions ici contre 2 et de l'autre
côté par contre ici trois pions contre 4
donc il faut compter là où l avantage
donc les blancs ont plutôt un avantage
toutefois les dames et au centre alors
que les noirs un avantage à l'oeil droit
mais qui peut pas leur servir pour
lancer une attaque puisque les pièces
sont beaucoup trop mais c'est un thème
fondamental or le coup suivant des
blancs est intéressant c'est 3 évident
commenté console c'est un coup de
consolidation sont peut-être que les
blancs ont simplement envie de s'en
doute de sortir la dame par exemple en
f3 est simplement protégé
et pas défendre avec un coup qu'on me
foute roi qui boucherait cette tour ils
veulent développer sans doute leur fou
par exemple en f4 si la dame et en f3
donc on attaquant la dame ici pouvoir
angers 5
donc il faut donc protéger ce cavalier
des centrales c'est sans doute tout à
fait tout à fait logique food et c'est
d'avoir les noirs se développe
ça c'est logique d'un restaurant c'est
leur attaque qui ont baissé alors si les
noirs protéger par tous et si ce serait
une faute
on prendrait simplement le fou et ça
casse il faudrait que les gens
reprennent avec le pion et c'est pas bon
la paire de foule à faire espère de fond
final donc ça sera un gros avantage pour
les blancs je voulais éviter ce genre de
coup évidemment
donc on protège autrement le pion 17 ont
fait d'un v6 m6 très intéressant simple
et on évite éventuellement de se faire
chasser la dame par un concombre ou f4
que regagnant le temps sur la dame donc
four b3 alors ça toujours selon de coûts
très intéressant la laine double
avantage c'est que 1
il enlève le fou d'une case où il est en
prise saclay noir pour regagner le temps
à l'attaquant déjà c'est plus possible
et de hibou ch
aussi l'action nadal mord sur le cube et
2 donc on va pouvoir sortir le fouet de
cases blanches de cases noires ici donc
le coup simon et noir s'explique ici
quand on a compris ça ouais à 5
voilà donc l'attention si je bouge le
fou avec attention je peux exposer à au
cou à 4 le fonds doit bouger
et puis on vient de tomber mais quand
même fou et 3 voilà donc les blancs
n'ont pas peur pourquoi pas ce qui crée
une contrevenants imaginons que les
noirs jouent le coup à 4 qu'est ce qui
se passe à ce que le foot doit bouger on
perd le pion non alors que c'est alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire il faudrait
qu est ce qui se passerait il serait
peut-être un coup comme
alors cavalier seul alors pourquoi alors
oui mais quand même je peux prendre le
cavalier ici cette attaque là et alors
le problème c'est que le cavaliere cinq
attaques le concède c'est ça ton qu il
faudrait défendre dans ce cas là la dame
et tatati faut défendre
peut-être part d'amd 8 et là on aurait
un problème parce qu'il y aurait sans
doute cavalli prendre cet échec d'un
prendre pourrait maintenant à inventer
pour sortir le fouet et encore plus fort
peut-être non je pense est fausse et
saigne ça marche pas protégé donc il
faudrait maintenant sortir le fouet par
exemple ces deux et on à la paire de fou
donc on comprend l'idée c'est que fou ou
3 on n'a pas peur de quoi cas on peut
jouer au foot roi puisque la dame est
attaqué et en fait cette idée c'est que
cette dame a pas de case parce que si
elle bouge
du coup si elle peut pas venir en bessin
qu'à cause du collier ne peut pas
attention elle peut pas venir non plus
en b 4 à cause du pion c3 donc elle peut
pas rester sur cette colonne tout en
étant attaqué par le faux 3 avec la
menace carl f 5 voire même cavalier
prendre 6 aussi d'ailleurs car les pros
si spécial parce que le foot protège le
cavalier et la dame devrait d'abord par
et la menace du fou et ensuite on sortir
les cavaliers alors donc seul coup
maintenant pour les noirs c'est de jouer
faux c'est simple parce que sinon si la
dame sort évident de la colombe et on a
plus de problème sur la colonne d
anjouan fous ces cinq les noirs menace
toujours à 80
c'est intéressant et bien tant pis pour
topalov c'est pas grave
tourner un quand même donc j'ai pas peur
du coup à 4 heures ils se gênent pas
évident car ce qu'il faut savoir comme
ce qui exclut ces mené au score on est à
la 7e il est mené 2 1 donc il a plu deux
parties la cité l'a8 pour revenir donc
il faut qu'ils prennent des risques
donc il va en profiter de ce dernier
coup droit d un pur comme ce qui pour
tenter quand même d'aller grappiller un
pion pour essayer de gagner la partie
donc il joue à quatre mois mais topalov
à vue
ouais c'est secouer quand même dangereux
puisque après fou ces deux et d'un prend
b2 évidemment les blancs ont lâché le
pion b2 mais il ya une compensation il
va falloir suivre ça c'est le coup j'ai
alors voilà donc fou j'essaie alors le
premier coup je sais que c'est quoi pour
le voir c'est que les blancs menaces ou
précise qu' on prend d'un prend derrière
et hongrois totalement à l'ouest
si les noirs prenez le fou des quatre on
pourrait ensuite prendre en plus de la
tour avec la tour qui viendra attaqué le
roi évidemment alors et c'est compliqué
parce que sauf on prend des quatre le
fou ces deux est plus protégé mais alors
aussi les blancs il va encore montrer
les menaces parce que non seulement
menace ici aussi mais alors il ya aussi
cette menace tombe est un qui peut
grappiller le tombé c'est sans compter
aussi que si on élimine lecavalier 6 le
fou 17 ici peut être en prise par la
tour d un donc dès qu'on bouge
lecavalier se fout pas sauter donc c'est
très compliqué donc on est rentré dans
une phase extrêmement tactique il ya du
jeu
il faudrait quelques calculs et
quasiment toutes les branches alors
imaginons que les noirs jouent le coup
par exemple fou prend des cats qui est
tout à fait envisageable
on n'est qu'à l'idée évidemment c'est ce
que tu disais c'est que le fou ces deux
formes effectivement parce que la fraude
est sans doute reprendre de la tour
pourquoi parce qu'on garde comme ça une
attaque sur le fou 17 et après d'un
profond cavaliers alors ici en plus on
peut menacer du coup pour g4 avec
attaques sur l'euro menace est au projet
7 et un math rapide et si les noirs jour
j'ai six ils affaiblissent
irrémédiablement et cases noires avec
g et en plus le fou 17 et d'attaquer
donc comment faire c'est pas évident
pour les noirs si on joue encore un coup
comme fou c'est si ça peut être
intéressant puisque on attaque la dame
sur d'alger 3 mais on peut encore jouer
d'investissement on avait en course à ce
qu'on peut pas jouer tour g4 iliad un
grand fou voilà avait donc ça c'était
jouable pour les noirs cette vente
c'était compliqué mais jouable alors au
lieu de quoi ici kamski a choisi un
autre coup peut-être peut-être mon
précieux finalement peut-être que [ __ ]
en d4 était peut-être mieux au vu de
cette variante il a joué cavalier des
cinq villes et c'est donc évidemment il
n'y a plus la menace estime l'intéressé
qui savent allier aussi est protégé par
pure oc c bouche l'action de cette tour
donc il est à l'air d'avoir moins de
danger et garde une menace faut prendre
cavaliers suivi de d'un prof ou alors là
dessus topalov joue le coup ses cadres
alors voilà donc créé en compte contre
menace donc on est en plein dedans alors
c'est compliqué parce que on voit bien
le câble est en prise mais évidemment
mon temps le cavalier des quatre est en
plus du tout avec la dame b2 qui protège
derrière le foot c'est deux seraient en
prise on se dit mais
raté un truc il a raté un truc d'or
c'est ce que fait comme ce qu'il faut
prendre des quatre caisses qui a vu
topalov regarder très jolie ou
intermédiaire donc ça c'est fort dans le
détroit
ça c'est fort parce qu'alors l'idée d'un
des trois c'est que je protège le foot
bien sûr mais je venais à se regarder au
passage tourne toujours ces histoires de
menaces intermédiaires et oui ça c'est
fort donc là ici le nas matt tout
simplement d'un proche 7 maths et amath
puisque le fou protège là donc c'est
c'est la menace ultime il faut
évidemment la part et donc les noirs ont
pas le choix il peut jouer soit g6 soit
le coût de la partie f5 qui affaiblit
peut-être un peu on a toujours peur de
pousser on dit souvent que le pion f
trop tôt tu connais cet adage c'est vrai
quant à dire il faut jamais poussé le
pion et or dès maintenant alors topal
choisi de prendre en d4 et les noirs
n'ont pas le choix de prendre la dame et
pour se diriger à deux pièces de pièces
parce que si les noirs font regarder
après tout reprendra on a un problème
c'était un cavalier fou emprise
il faudrait jouer cavalier b6 est à
prévoir des tourbes et on a des soucis
est-ce que cavaler dès qu'il bouge elf
ou 17 et entre le rallye à tout et à
tout est en prison
c'est pas du tout facile voilà c'est pas
comme moi donc ça pose des vrais
problèmes donc après d'emprunt on n'a
pas le choix pleinement il faut prendre
ces deux et maintenant
puis on prend des 5 et les noirs ne
peuvent pas reprendre des cinq sous
peine du simple dames prendre des cinq
échecs attaque le fou 17 et si les noirs
vous le contour et 7 pour protéger le
fou évidemment il ya le risque simple
tour cette attaque à la fois de la dame
prend tout s'est tu es aussi tout
reprend 17 très difficile appareil le
seul coup ce serait je vous ai huit qui
tient par miracle on joue on pourrait
jouer tour c'est un menaces après deux
tours c'est cette enfin on fait un
triple agent fait c'est horrible tour ou
un aussi bien sûr infections je sais pas
si le terme auch et appropriée mais
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est pas
tout à fait exact avant tout à fait donc
ses plans des cinq donc c'est pas simple
pour les noirs ici donc là comme ce qui
tente un autre coup ces dames 3 2 en
fait c'est intéressant l'idée évidemment
c'est que sur qui on prend 1,6 on peut a
priori reprendre du fou puisque la dame
à deux protège ta vu topalov là dessus
ça c'est important d'indécis ça c'est
joli ça c'est joli alors l'idée de d'un
v6 se dire en fait peut pas on peut pas
prendre ici et aux menaces
au contraire on menace aussi de prendre
en russie avec la dame qui protège et la
cour donc de protection est un pion
énorme puisque là aussi c'est plus qu'à
jouer cet essai c'est fini ça serait
terrible un v6 et fort si les noirs joué
le coup puis on prend des cinq qui a
l'air de dire bonjour et zou ça résout
les problèmes bien tout simplement on
peut jouer dans prendrait cette attaque
le fou 17 et menaces dame dans nos tours
prendre des singles et aussi pourquoi
pas tours 7
bien sympathique pour les blancs on peut
pas jouer tours fc être non plus qu'il
serait intéressant parce que la torah 8
serait en prison
donc c'est très très délicat pour les
noirs ce superbe coup ici d'autre part
l'offre d'un v6 kamski finalement laisse
les choses en l'état et se dit bon mais
je vais essayer de quand même d'être
contrôlés contre je parce que là on a
quand même un pion pas ses protégés sur
nadal et dames évidemment ça peut être
très paralysant pour une aura donc à
trois ils poussent pour l'instant parce
que les landes menace pas non plus de
maturité dans des tours sète fouet cette
pardon de la part des de la part des
blancs l'âge active le fou alors l'idée
de jouer fouet cette c2 a finalement je
vais pouvoir pousser ses pions il sera
protégé par le fou et en plus le fou
contrôle toujours là la case qu'on
appelle la casse de promotion donc là où
le et à prayssas et paralysant pour
réparer la fossette
il faut jouer la tour a pas laissé la
qualité la position de l'année pour lui
et à regarder d'anne decis la dame
viennent protéger le fou et attaque fou
17 qui alluma l'unc a du mal à trouver
une case et peut-être aussi
le but de secours à trois peut-être de
recycler sur la case à quatre ça peut
être aussi l'idée évidemment le fou va
pouvoir venir là alors on peut se poser
la question est ce que les noirs
pourraient jouer le coup tout à fait fou
c'est 8 qui mais c'est très passif avec
le fou doit revenir à la maison
non on a des honda les soucis mais bon
les noirs peu de talent peuvent
envisager pourquoi pas de prendre de
prendre des 5 alors prendre
éventuellement dans ce cas là on
reprendront dès 7 8
oui parce que surtout reprend et à tour
primates dont il faut faire très
attention c'est très tactique sa série
je serai tactile
une autre possibilité aussi s'il joue le
coup j'ai entraînement des dames c'est 7
avec l'idée des 6-17 et si les noirs
prennent ici on vous le regardez le
superbe fou et 6 c'est énorme
parce qu'on menace regardez en menace
maths et il ya aussi tout un pan 8 qui
menacent maths et si les noirs vivent
juste part je prends en prendre tout
reprendre au printemps menace toujours
de maths tour là et d'un promat on peut
pas parler d'eux avant de donner du
matériel donc donc c'est chaud alors
donc toi celui d'anne decis ça pose un
souci donc kamski donc au refus cette
variante plus on n'a pas envie de jouer
tout s'est vite aussi
oui comprends parce que comme toi oui on
en dire on n'a pas envie de retourner de
là ou bien ça c'est clair
donc fou à 4 mais c'est peut-être que
c'est peut-être quand même le mieux à
jouer malgré tout sauf en cas de retard
la tacle tout la tour des hommes et on a
toujours la possibilité aux déchets
clients de faire un taux intermédiaire
quand on est attaqué surtout quand
soukous intervenir ses échecs
donc dans prend échec et ça y est on a
un pion passer tout seul parce qu'une
fois qu'on élimine espions échec au roi
des infos par un échec
moi je suis été forcée et or des
olympiens qui peut aller à dame direct
alors attention tout de suite puisque la
dame à 2 s'échangeraient et le froid cap
tiendrait sans doute le pion en respect
ici donc voilà
tope là se pressent pas ils jouent tour
à un attaque déjà la dame 1 2 et où
vaste d'am dam c4 la dame reste sur la
diagonale blanche parce qu'elle veut pas
permettre pas permettre aux six en tout
cas de permettre en échange des dames et
après le fou veiller à 1,17 et on a
bloqué ce fameux pions passé puis nous
mêmes on a deux pions ici intéressant ça
serait une erreur donc les blancs
harcèle la dame ça c'est important
ou alors si elle reste sur la blanche on
va sans doute peut-être aller grappiller
puis ont baissé
et oui parce que si elle était venu
effectivement on va on va montrer ça
c'est bien vu c était venu en b3 on
aurait sans doute un peu joutes
oratoires taux prend à trois puisque le
fou au sed protège et après la dame et
protéger le même donc ça marcherait pas
on tour dames c4
la dame a pas de cas si on vit en b 3 3
à 3 le fou protège et donc pousser deux
voilà on fait la même chose qui se passe
ici abordé le fou empêche la tour de
prendre la dame et là on fait pareil le
fou empêche de prendre la dame alors ça
c'est important de le juge cette
position là où on est quand même au lit
de façon générale alors comment je vis
de qui al'avantage c'est pas clair parce
qu'on a trois pions ici contre 3 ici les
noirs ont bien deux pions passé lee pace
liés
alors ils sont pas tout à fait lit est
sûre il faudra qu'il avance un peu pour
lier presque livre façon quasi ils sont
liés potentiellement il faudrait que
j'aie b4 is really est vraiment quoi
mais son plaisir on vraiment plus
uniquement liés et les blancs ont su par
contre ce gros pions des 500 francs qui
lui aussi est pas loin de la promotion
qui possède t mobiliser parce que si on
plus assez soutenue mais on est bloqué
et quoi bloquer alors c'est pas évident
de devoir qui al'avantage or topalov va
montrer qu'en fait c'est lui qui
al'avantage on avait par des coups très
précis il faut pas se tromper
en tout cas des coups agressifs ou d'amd
cette attention quand même parce que
c'est de ça fait peur je pense que les
noirs sont enlève un peu mieux dans
cette position évidente tant par lafarge
ou agressif alors il a une pièce an
passé mais regardez ce pion à trois
aussi passé mais bon la différence voire
décès que là les blancs contrôler la
case de promotion alors qu'ici pas du
tout voilà le fou et socquettes blanches
et latour bloc
voilà le seul truc c'est si les noirs et
jouer jouer b5 bk placé l'asadho bendré
très inquiétant est très difficile donc
ici dans l'es7 l'idée séduit dans de
permettre des six là il ya plus d'un
probable
et en plus on attaque au passage on
attaque aussi le pion à 2 et des six
mois c'est l'heure maintenant ça on
appelle ça un
qu'on l'appelle d'ailleurs moi non plus
mais à vrai dire ça ce soutien très bien
voilà ça voilà l'opinion soutient le
fouet le foot est allé soutien mutuel
points voilà ça c'est important c'est la
cohésion sociale des pièces des pièces
déchets et pourtant ces renvois bien que
développe d'abord à jouer baffe 17 ans
avec au fond qui contrôle toujours cette
caste de promotion c'est faux et là donc
les noirs seller dans ce qu'on a dit il
faut jouer aussi leur avantage donc là
les blancs doivent jouer extrêmement
précis s'il veut pas tomber dans deux
paires dans cette partie ça peut aller
très très vite puisque b5
voilà donc la menace des noirs ckoi et
k3 et b2c c'est fini parce que même si
le pion on pousse on tombe on sacrifie
une pièce pour le pion et puis nous on a
récupéré une toux et on a encore en
pions passé c'est l'avantagé en avoir
deux alors dame bessette de la part de
la part des blancs alors l'idée sans
doute c'est que si les noirs du d4 voilà
essayer dès cette année que l'idée si la
tour enfin si on attaque ici à la fois
le tombé 4 et la tour 17 alors où va la
tour si par exemple la tour vient b8 on
peut faire échec avec dame échec et
surtout reprend on peut envisager un
simple d'un point b 4 par exemple
voilà donc on peut récupérer on peut
récupérer le pion mais il ya quand même
des engagements cause de ce pion oui
donc
là les noirs auraient sans doute eu
intérêt à jouer des cadres dans cette
position au lieu de quoi comme ce qu'ils
jouent tous eu des huit qui est
peut-être un tout petit peu imprécis
c'est moins précis parce qu est-ce qu on
est ce qu'on dit pas souvent
aurélie d'ailleurs que quand on a des
points pas s'il faut les pousser
je dirai pas ce qu'ils ont tendance à
non seulement a menacé de faire nommer à
bloquer l'adversaire en défendant aussi
parce qu'ils sont obligés de mobiliser
leurs pièces pour éviter qu'on aille
adam donc ça enlève des pièces l attaque
qu on a donc là qu'elle soit comme ceux
qui auraient oublié cette règle de base
je crois pas qu'elle qui est oublié mais
là du coup mettre simplement la
précision ce qui est arrivé donc les
jouets tout réduite
alors c'est intéressant aussi parce
qu'on dit souvent si les tours doivent
être derrière les pions passé parce
qu'évidemment il disait da lapa la
poussée sauf que là il ya quand même un
pion qui peut dévier cette tour à tout
moment décider 7 et des huit dames sera
une menace perpétuelle
donc il faut faire attention donc ici
dans le c7 de la part d'auto pas
l'intérêt dames c'est cette c'est que
évident si dame prend dames on prend du
plomb et là tout est attaqué on gagne en
quittant sans compter qu'il est le tout
le fou on perdrait le fou en fait voilà
et les noirs ne peuvent pas jouer des
quatre à cause de d'en prendre
et d'ailleurs même on peut supposer
weave la menace aussi c'est d'un
programme puisque le foot c'est de ce
prêt permet donc là c'est vraiment
embêtant ce que jouer
oui c'est un gros coup de défense c'est
un beau coup de défense
c'est pour ça que le coup sans doute ici
b4 étaient plus précis et percutant
voilà pour ce qui est dans cette
position est sans doute gagnant sur la
variante sans doute la plus tendue 17
mai tout simplement maintenant ont joué
trop bas 8
c'est pas pareil est-ce qu'on peut plus
jouer dames c'est cette wii est donc ici
sur des huit dames elles feraient tout
simplement tout reprend dame et son fou
prend dame simplement tout reprend et on
a ici deux pions passé lié dame soutenu
la tour des huit clients défense
pourront éviter les mains du corps et
compagnie donc avec dès qu'on a joué les
trois opus tous tiers là aussi elle est
finie pour les noirs donc elle a donc
erreur de cannes ce qui est ce niveau là
donc très important de tournant du match
parce que cannes ce qui doit quand même
essayer d'égaliser pour revenir dans le
match et à ce moment là ils jouent tous
rêvé 8 au lieu de jouer ce coup b4 très
fort donc peut-être mon image dans ses
sept tours c8 de la part des noirs voilà
donc la regarder cette donc on avait dit
la menace un mail à évidemment si d'un
programme en fait tout reprend et hop
tout de suite le fouet de nouveaux
protégés n'y a pas de problème donc
c'est ce que font quand même les bains
n'y a pas le choix
un tour prend on protège de nouveau le
fouet la différence c'est que maintenant
le 17 et on va faire là on va récupérer
quelque chose donc ça c'est ça c'est
embêtant
les mouches ont changé d'âne ans quelle
que soit parce que même si les noirs
pouces on peut envisager que les blancs
mais du coup face aux sacrifices et du
moment qu'ils ont récupéré une tourbe il
récupérer du matériel s'affronter qui
sont proches du gain du match puisqu'il
ya plus deux parties celle là est la
dernière très lourd donc floue mais
trois fous fous bien la part de deux
caps kick et sans doute l'erreur final
il faut bien calés rebond parce qu'on se
dit effectivement ça a l'air pas mal
parce que si dame fou prend tous
reprendront joue b4 et après et b3 à b2
on se dit que le food et 8 pourra pas
venir un f6 contrôler mes 2 il n'a pas
tout vu parce que tout reprend
non pas tout reprendre il a joué tour d
un ici topalov que n'avait sans doute
pas vu comme ce qui menace de faire
damer de gagner une tournette et le fou
de garde d'un contrôle sobeca et en plus
sombre menace pattes
il faut jouer il faut perdre un temps
décroché huit dames échec regarder et
surtout reprend fou prend ça c'est malin
et regarder l'idée de base c'est à dire
que la tension moi je me lasse tout
simplement tout reprend voilà et après
tout reprendre j'ai une pièce de plus
c'est un pion tu pourras pas aller à
dame parce que je contrôle très bientôt
et qui font donc là ça oblige comme ce
qui a essayé de trouver des astuces avec
issifou ses deux meilleurs dès
maintenant le problème c'est qu'ils
lâchent le pion le pion le pion à deux
tours d'essai 1-1 plonge ici sur les
deux ça tient plus il arrive plus à
pousser ses pions db4 ici qu'on tromper
totalement kamski ici tout reprend à
deux ont regardé ça y est hyper le pion
à 2 c'est fini parce que même en
sacrifiant les blancs ont pas de
problème même sacrifié une tour contre
le fou on voit bien qu'ils ont une pièce
de plus donc c'est tromper comme ce qui
dans son calcul
le raté b3 par les tours à huit ans plus
tôt par le fait précis jusqu'au bout
alors dès maintenant sur b dehors des
l'astuce tout simplement fou et 6 échecs
or aux infos par et l'échec et le fou
ensuite va gober qui ont baissé une
défense parle attaque une contre attaque
et l'idée de jouer tous ravis de il faut
que les noirs protège de cette attaque
et après je vous la tour en b 8 et on va
contrôler par derrière le pian ce qui
est la meilleure des défenses donc ici
roi f7 et regarder tout simplement de
tours minute voilà c'est fini
ouais pourquoi parce que c'est de caser
sur noir on voit bien et le fou ils
contrôlent que les cases blanches jamais
les noirs pour en contrôler la classe b
2 pour pousser ses pions
la tour a aucun moyen pour refaire le
tour même en faisant tout on va pas trop
loin avec retard matériel
il ya une tour entière donc là il joue
encore un peu comme ce qui parce que
c'est la fin du match si personne ne l'a
donc tout un échec pour l'honneur dans
l'es5 fossé est hissée sans doute à ce
moment là qu'il a raté un truc
malheureusement pour lui et l'a regardé
superbe fouet suite ça c'est beau parce
que évidemment sur tora 2 quelle idée de
ce qu'ils encourent de proposer b2 et
bien d'essayer de récupérer du matériel
en jouant fuite fou prend g7 et ça y est
ça tient en trois la classe b 2 on n'a
plus peur avec la tourbe et 8 et le fuji
7 on peut pas pousser b2 et surtout
racette qui protège la classe g 7
ouais c'est qu'on contrôle pub et de m
l'idée c'est de dire je vais jouer le
roi roi là et après je pousse sauf que
tranquille n'a pas peur topalov qui joue
h 4 et s'est terminée à bandes dont elle
a pas trop de joueurs s'ils jouent ici
peut tenter de
il peut tenter d'avancer mais simplement
on va jouer des coups comme tour au set
et après on va faire comprendre gsm
c'est fini on contrôle la casse g2 et
s'est terminée en jouant h4 on empêche
le coup le mât du couloir en fait donc
raté pour kramnik pour regagner
décidément mais j'ai dit non mais c'est
le cas il ya quand même ça finisse a
fini par ace et un deux syllabes ses
chroniques et l'autre mais comme ce qui
est américain il n'est pas russe voilà
donc voilà pour ce match fini à ce
moment là du match puisque trois pour
autant pas l'offre il reste une partie
donc pas la peine de jouer la dernière
donc total doit jouer face à l'inde ça
c'est la fin de l'année ça va être un
match ça tu as la suisse et le
championnat du monde féminin
je suis aussi un peu ou pas non c'est
kosteniuk battu de ces la chinoise
est-ce que tu suis où il fan tu sais la
petite tu as regardé un peu c'est parti
tu pense qu'elle va on la voit arriver
au niveau de judit polgar est-ce que tu
pas impossible dit ouais ouais parce que
c'est 15 ans je crois en 2000 déjà 2000
presque 2006 et oui c'est un fait
significatif à cet âge là d'avoir ce
niveau je pense qu'elle a quand même de
belles années devant elle
- peut-être bien compliqué à ces âges là
que vraiment on progresse on intègre
bien les choses et en plus de ça elle a
tout le temps pour progresser davantage
c'est super alors on va rappeler ici que
tu donnes des cours d'échecs
oui c'est vrai à paris donc uniquement
aux membres de ton club ou aussi à
d'autres enchaînements les écoles de
paris aussi pour faire ça dans les échos
mais tu fais ça en le soir comment ça se
passera après mon travail j'ai des
employeurs sympathique ouais
et puis occasionnellement chez les
familles qui m'ont demandé de venir
comme ça en tête actuellement
j'étais disponible et est disponible
pour ceux qui voudraient suivre des
cours oui tant ou tant redoutée dans ton
agenda sur le foulard il n'est pas finie
et adaptable mais disons que c'est alors
comment on fait si on veut avoir des
cours de d'oreiller d'appel tout ridé
d'accord pour apprendre à jouer aux
échecs
comment on fait c'est impossible ça il
faut joindre lutèce échec c'est le
teston club et des seychelles
on trouve sur internet c'est ça le tien
ces chèques en difficulté ou
éventuellement on appelle la fédération
puisque la fédération aussi à tes
coordonnées d'occident et éventuellement
si vous voulez donc vous êtes sur paris
vous voulez suivre des cours avec
aurélie qui donne des cours sur paris
pour moi pas mais vous appelez la
fédération du tfc cheikh vous aurez des
cours sur vous avez vu toutes les
subtilités du jeu d'échecs que koné
aurélie et les techniques et voyez la
créativité regardé l'émission qu'on a
fait sur aussi sur la partie
ro quatre oures il montre sa partie
aussi donc à la gagner face aux grands
maîtres
féminin almira skripchenko multiple
champion de france et orly a gagné voyez
donc c'est pas n'importe quel professeur
pour apprendre à progresser aux échecs
vous expliquera ce qu'il faut faire et
ne pas faire
merci aurait ni d'être venus sur des
choses allaient si on espère te revoir
sur le plateau d'attentats merci
beaucoup je vous le dis au revoir et à
bientôt
merci nous est fidèle sur diagonale tv
voix